[Music]
on this saturday night
one dose or two the debate over the
second vaccine shock
we should not be waffling on this it's
too
too critical right now plus the change
to temperature that may speed up the
vaccination program
the new challenges facing the u.s as it
aims to get every american vaccinated by
summer
justice reform in canada it's rooted in
the judgment
is it time to judge the judges and they
were trailblazers in the nhl
the push to get more diverse players to
follow in their skates
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us as vaccine deliveries ramp up across
this country there is a push to make the
shots go
even further in canada over 1.4 million
doses have now been administered
the majority of those vaccines are
coming from pfizer biontech
new data shows it's highly effective
after just one dose
and as abigail beeman reports some
health experts say canada should focus
on getting one shot
into as many arms as possible
british columbia and quebec are both
reporting the pfizer biontech vaccine is
about 80 percent effective after just
one dose
we should not be
waffling on this it's too
too critical while in a letter to the
editor in the new england journal of
medicine
dr danuda skoronsky argues the first
dose is more than
90 percent effective she still supports
getting a second
shot but wants to make sure everyone
vulnerable gets their first dose
first hospitalizations and deaths that
accrue
now should be considered vaccine
preventable
with the first dose the data is
certainly encouraging jason kinderchuck
says there's still much we don't know
about vaccine effectiveness
does that extend out uh far beyond where
we would normally get the second dose
is it only sustained for a short period
of time
and that's really the question that we
you know can't answer at this point
meanwhile pfizer applied to the u.s food
and drug administration with data to
show the vaccine can be stored at much
warmer temperatures around minus 20
degrees celsius for two weeks this new
storage option would offer
pharmacies and vaccination centers
greater flexibility
in how they manage their vaccine supply
pfizer tells global news it will make
the same request to health canada in the
coming weeks and it could make a big
difference here where remote locations
aren't using the vaccine due to the
challenges
we stand by ready to assess it when they
apply
the first dose efficacy is also under
review that's a very live
discussion right now and the analysis is
going on but it
is incredible i think that we have such
an efficacious tool dr tam says data
showing the vaccine is highly effective
among the most
elderly and vulnerable members of
society is also promising
noting clinical trials had many younger
healthier participants
robin abigail beeman in ottawa thanks
abigail
the spread of the highly transmissible
kova 19 variants has prompted the
federal
government to extend the canada-u.s
border closure
all land border crossings will remain
closed to non-essential travel
until at least march 21st that day will
mark exactly one year since the border
was shut down in an effort
to slow the spread of the virus the
pandemic is just one topic prime
minister justin trudeau will discuss
with u.s president joe biden
next week the two leaders are scheduled
to hold a virtual bilateral meeting on
tuesday
it will be biden's first official
meeting with a foreign head of
government
since taking office the president is
investing in more vaccines already 1.9
million shots are being given each day
and cases dropped by 29 compared to this
time
last week but as reggie jacini explains
despite those positive developments
there are still significant challenges
it's a small sign of progress in the
united states covet 19 cases and
hospitalizations are at five week lows
we have made progress but we have a long
way to go while there is a light at the
end of the tunnel
the road to recovery is lined with
constant reminders of the toll this
pandemic has taken
500 000 americans will have died
from covet 19. slowing that rise
is a massive undertaking touring
pfizer's facility in michigan on friday
president joe biden lauded efforts to
ramp up production to 200 million shots
by may
but at the same time offered a dose of
reality that doesn't mean it'll be in
all americans arms
but enough vaccine will be available by
that time
many states are struggling to administer
what vaccine they have
meaning they could be sitting on
stockpiles it is critical
that we figure out any way possible to
try to double or even triple the vaccine
numbers that we have
the white house has a target of
vaccinating all adults by summer
hoping for a return to normalcy by
year's end but there
are challenges emerging variants could
become dominant strains in the near
future
and threaten efforts to lower case
numbers vaccination programs should be
thinking about
a booster dose option they should be
thinking about changing the strain like
we do that in flu
vaccine meanwhile a key indicator of
public health
is signaling distress life expectancy in
the united states
dropped by one full year in the first
half of 2020
to 77.8 years but for black americans
it dropped by almost three years
highlighting disparities faced by racial
communities
during this pandemic there is just a
consistent
gap across the board in everything from
education
finance and income and every time we
come up with solutions
we find that they're necessary but not
sufficient and health officials say
controlling this virus
isn't going to end decades of inequities
faced by minority communities and the
white house has actually made vaccine
equity
a key component in its strategy to
combat this pandemic
they're also working to instill
confidence in a population that includes
some of the country's
most vulnerable robin reggie jacoby in
washington thanks reggie
in the southern u.s warmer temperatures
are bringing much needed relief to the
storm-battered region
today president biden declared a major
disaster in texas
allowing more federal funding to flow to
the state two
back-to-back storms are being blamed for
at least 69 deaths in several states
millions of americans still don't have
safe drinking water and tens of
thousands
remain without power a developing story
in colorado where a passenger jettis
landed safely
after plane parts fell from the sky on a
residential neighborhood
this large piece of the united airlines
boeing 777 landed in a yard
barely missing the home other metal
debris fell on a sports field
and on roads it happened shortly after
the plane took off on route from denver
to honolulu
with 240 people on board there are no
reports of any injuries
in newfoundland and labrador the
deadline for mail-in ballots has been
extended
the provincial election was disrupted by
spike in covet 19 cases
and election officials were forced to
cancel in-person voting
but not everyone is confident in how the
process is unfolding
as ross lord explains the turmoil could
continue even after the votes are
tallied
a makeshift plan that relies on mail-in
ballots and a four-week delay for
results
could be just the start of election
turmoil in newfoundland and labrador
no matter which party ends up with the
most votes the election is widely
expected to end up
in court i think it seems likely it's
hard to tell at this early stage i've
definitely heard rumblings about various
kinds of constitutional challenges that
are being contemplated
something had to give election workers
many elderly volunteers
were quitting afraid they'd contract
covet 19 at polling stations
just hours before the february 13th
election date
the province's chief electoral officer
finally settled on a safer option
voting exclusively through the mail it
is a tried and true method of
making sure that people are able to
participate in the election
but some analysts question whether
extending voting day for the entire
province is allowed under election law
and they say the mail-in system could
deny some voters their rights
especially in parts of labrador where
slow mail service
language barriers and spotty phone and
internet services
can undermine applying for and returning
ballots
which must be postmarked for return by
march 12th
even without court challenges there are
concerns voters who are nervous about
the outbreak
and frustrated by election disruptions
have lost their faith
now it appears at this point that the
the die has been cast and they're going
forward
but it does re leave a question
about how much confidence people will
have in the election results
the elections office says it's using
extra tech resources
and it's hired a call center to help
smooth out the process
but there's still a long way to go
before anyone can call this election
a success ross lord global news
now to the allegations of inappropriate
behavior leveled against canada's former
top soldier
general jonathan vance canadians will
soon hear from someone at the very heart
of those allegations
our ottoman bureau chief mercedes
stephenson broke the story earlier this
month
and has a preview of what's coming up
tomorrow on the west block
general jonathan vance swore to stamp
out sexual misconduct in the canadian
forces
he even made it possible to dismiss
troops accused of sexual misconduct
concerned that existing mechanisms did
not allow for severe enough punishment
now general vance is under investigation
by military police after global news
reported allegations of sexual
misconduct
one of an inappropriate relationship
with a subordinate while she was under
his command
and while he was chief of the defense
staff he is also alleged to have sent an
inappropriate email to a young soldier
who he offered career advice to vance
was also investigated in 2015 by
military police
over a third allegation of inappropriate
behavior with a woman he outranked
who is now his wife vance has denied
all of the allegations but this week on
the west block
we are going to hear from a woman at the
center of this story
telling her story and what it means for
women in the canadian military
on friday defense minister harjit sajin
was grilled by opposition
mps on what he knew about allegations
brought to his attention
in 2018 by the canadian forces ombudsman
sajin refused to say what he knew or who
he told
what did you do with that information
our conversations at the ombudsman are
obviously kept
confidential but one thing i can assure
you that any allegations
or any information that were brought
forward was always quickly
and then taken to the appropriate
authorities for the appropriate action
senior government officials have not
said why they did not choose to further
investigate those allegations
prime minister justin trudeau has not
said if he was aware of the allegations
mercedes stephenson global news ottawa
in its crackdown on protesters in
myanmar security forces opened fire
killing at least two people
riot police used water cannons and tear
gas to disperse demonstrations in
mandalay
the second biggest city in the country
which is also known as burma
elsewhere vigils were held for a 20 year
old woman who died yesterday
after being shot in the head during a
demonstration earlier this month
it's been nearly three weeks since the
military seized control of the country
and imprisoned democratic leader aung
san tsuchi
coming up justice reform rooting out
discrimination in canada's justice
system
the canadian government has tabled a
bill to repeal 20 mandatory minimum
sentences
the justice minister believes they
disproportionately hurt indigenous and
black people
but will this move address systemic
racism in the court system
michael couture looks at justice reform
that has the judges
being judged being stopped by police
even being
just harassed for no reason growing up
as an indigenous person in thunder bay
ontario chief derrick fox remembers
feeling targeted
as a result of systemic racism it's a
problem the government is trying to fix
by removing
some mandatory minimum penalties for
certain offenses
but fox wonders what is being done to
root out racism
in the judicial system we're not just
going to see a sudden
decrease of indigenous and or blacks or
people of color
in within our jails justice minister
david lametty says judges and
prosecutors want the discretion
to use a conditional sentence instead of
the mandatory minimum
but he also admits there's a certain
degree of systemic racism
in the judicial system and he hopes a
bill already before parliament
will help we have a bill in front of in
front of parliament right now that would
train judges not only in sexual assault
but also other other social contracts
training
some community activists say new
training isn't enough to stop
old habits created by mandatory minimum
sentences
one idea is a system to judge judges
the goal is that this oversight
committee would
identify judges that have this bias
it's not going to be explicit it's
implicit
it's rooted in the judgment and they
would be barred from adjudicating cases
with minorities or indigenous
communities
many of the mandatory minimums the
liberals are targeting deal with drug
possession lamedi believes diversion
programs like drug
treatment can be an alternative to jail
sentences
but those programs are already
overburdened
sort of opening the floodgate around the
reduction in
in mandatory minimums could have an
impact in further uh increasing wait
lists
uh and time for people to access those
services the government has earmarked
more than 28 million dollars over the
next five years for these types of
programs
but minister lametty admits more funding
will be needed
mike lacouter global news ottawa
still have the vaccine risks and rewards
for pregnant women
prince philip is spending his fifth
night in hospital but did receive a
visitor
his son prince charles was escorted
through the back of the london hospital
and spent a half hour with his father
the 99 year old duke of edinburgh was
feeling unwell when he was admitted
tuesday as a precaution
he had been isolated at windsor castle
with the queen
at another hospital a newborn was named
after the
year 99-year-old phillip his
granddaughter princess eugenie
and her husband have named their baby
boy august phillip
hawk brooksbank he's the queen and
phillips ninth great-grandchild
and eleventh in line for the throne
pfizer and biontic have started testing
their cova-19 vaccine on pregnant women
the study involves four thousand women
in nine countries
including canada many public health
officials have recommended pregnant
women who are at high risk
take the vaccine even without proof it's
safe for them
and as su lingo explains some canadians
have already made their choice
calgary's kerry ray fuse is one of the
first in the world to receive the kovid
19 vaccine
as a breastfeeding mother i didn't want
to get it at first
but then once i started looking at the
actual research my opinion
changed very quickly and i was very
eager to get it
the respiratory therapist returned from
her maternity leave to the hospital last
month
and chose to be vaccinated my exposure
risk was very high
and then my risk of getting critically
ill with cobot is likely low
but i'm also seeing very vulnerable
patients throughout the day
because covid vaccines have not been
tested on pregnant or breastfeeding
women
some say they should not be offered the
shot until we have more data
dr jonathan zapersky feels they should
have the choice
i think everybody sort of needs to make
a decision uh
that takes into account their concerns
their personal risk factors
of both acquiring covet 19. his team
created a discussion framework
for women and health care providers do
the benefits outweigh the risks
most pregnant women with covid19 will
have mild symptoms
but eight to 11 percent will be
hospitalized
two to four percent will need intensive
care
there's also an increased risk of
preterm births
plus women are more likely to work in
front line health care
or essential service jobs they deserve
the opportunity to protect themselves
because they're putting themselves
putting themselves in harm's way on a
daily basis
anxiety levels could also be considered
is the mother more stressed with or
without the vaccine
it's scary you want baby to be safe and
healthy in your belly as long as
possible
stacy brecken is due in march she would
love to get the shot
i mean it would be really nice to have
the option
not only to protect myself but to
protect my family
sue lingo global news edmonton
diversity goals up next the nhl's push
to be more inclusive
that's grand slam number four for
japan's naomi osaka
the 20th tennis star beat out jennifer
brady at the australian open women's
final
osaka has won every major final she's
ever reached
it was brady's first and she put up a
good fight considering she had to
quarantine in her hotel room
for 15 days after a potential coveted
exposure on the flight over
the city of fredericton will honor
hometown hero willie o'ree
with a pair of skates these custom-made
skates honoring the nhl's first black
player
will be put on permanent display at
william replace in new brunswick's
capital
the skates were made in canada to
celebrate his achievements
the design features an image of o-ri his
number 22
and phrases that include diversity
equality
and inclusion it's been 63 years since
willie o'reilly broke the color barrier
in the national hockey league
yet diversity in the nhl today pales in
comparison
to other professional sports leagues but
as suzette francis tells us
the league is hoping to change that
william reed became the nhl's first
black player when he laced up his skates
for the boston bruins in a game against
the montreal canadiens
on january 18 1958
nearly two decades later bill riley
would join the washington capitals
making him the third black player in the
league
when i got there i said oh my goodness
it's easier to play up here than it is
in the miners
everybody's where they're supposed to be
on the ice but things in the majors
weren't as smooth
with riley facing racism on and off the
ice
you got called a lot of names and you've
got beers around last year you got
everything thrown at you trailblazers
such as oree and riley struggled with
racial inequality
but paved the way for many players of
color in the game today
the nhl has long used the phrase hockey
is for everyone
but only seven percent of its players
are from diverse backgrounds
something the league is hoping to change
what we can do from an inclusion point
of view
is to educate our allies and our
partners
to making the sport more welcoming so
that more kids of different backgrounds
participate in the sport
there are 44 active bipac players
currently in the league
and another 46 in the system in an
effort to rectify this
the league has established grassroots
programs to mentor
young players across north america it's
a cultural awakening that employment in
the front office has changed so that
kids
not only see people that look like
themselves on the ice that's where
former nhler anthony stewart comes in
[Applause]
the scarborough native who played
professional hockey for over a decade
calls a lack of diversity in the game a
socio-economic problem
it's way too expensive the cost of ice
is hundreds of dollars an hour
equipments and skates
you're at a disadvantage before you even
touch the ice stewart who coaches two
gthl teams has decided to pay it forward
by creating hockey quality an initiative
geared towards giving children from
diverse
communities a chance to make it for me
with my program in hockey quality
every dollar counts because it goes
directly towards
ice costs registration equipment costs
because within my network of my hockey
school and teams
there are people that need the help and
regardless of where things currently
stand
the nhl is hoping to become the most
inclusive league in the world
something stewart sees as a possibility
if there's 10 more people like-minded
that have the same goals
why not i say why not suzette francis
global news
toronto and that is global national for
this saturday night i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with the music of
canadian singer buffy st
marie little wheels spin and spin
big wheel turn around and around
little wheels spinning here she is
performing 55 years ago on pete seeger's
tv
show the indigenous musician and
activist is celebrating her 80th
birthday today
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
turn around and around
merry christmas jingle bells